singing for the Nobel Peace Prize winner
a mammoth event worthy of Nelson Mandela
the celebration of his life took place
in Africa's biggest football arena the
mood was a mixture of joyful remembrance
and grief
mourners came from all over the world
they included some 90 current and former
heads of state and government the event
brought together people who normally do
not sit together un secretary-general
ban ki-moon praised Mandela as a great
reconciler even beyond his death she
sacrificed so much I was willing to give
up everything here
for freedom and equality
for democracy and justice US President
Barack Obama compared Mandela's
achievements with the life work of
Mahatma Gandhi US President Abraham
Lincoln and American civil rights leader
Martin Luther King
he tells us what is possible not just in
the pages of history books but in our
own lives as well for South Africans
whose own lives were shaped by Mandela
the day had special meaning many
Johannesburg residents stayed up all
night hoping to get a seat in the
stadium even the bad weather couldn't
discourage them public transport could
barely keep up huge crowds formed with
bus stations they said the rear visors
would be shower on time but there's no
revilla for Vince 11 caps is anyone
personally fishing and it's not I a
celebration of one of the great men in
world history an unforgettable moment
for South Africa